la colchicine c'est un puissant anti
inflammatoire déjà utilisé pour traiter
la goutte
et comme ce médicament permet de réduire
l'inflammation les chercheurs de
l'institut de cardiologie de montréal
ont eu l'idée de tester son efficacité
contre la coved 19 et on verra pas
prévenir les complications et portant
les gens qui meurent de la kfw 19
subissent d'abord ce que les médecins
appellent une tempête inflammatoires à
l'opposé les enfants semblent mieux
protéger contre ce genre de
complications entre autres parce qu'ils
contrôlent mieux l'inflammation
lorsqu'ils ont le virus
les chercheurs espèrent donc un puissant
anti inflammatoire va amoindrir les
symptômes de la grippe 19 kouachi s'il
était le produit idéal parce qu'il était
beau il est disponible immédiatement et
ça nous a permis de lancer une étude
extrêmement rapidement pour mener
l'étude
l'institut de cardiologie a besoin de
6000 patients atteints du virus
dès qu'une personne aura un diagnostic
on lui fournira un numéro de téléphone
le passé avoir appelé pour parler
immédiatement à une infirmière je vais
vous dire la personne personne de
disponible pour parler aux gens donc
instantanément aux patients
l'inscription à l'étude se fera en ligne
ensuite tout sera fait à distance deux
cent mille comprimés de colchicine sont
déjà prêts dès qu'une personne est
inscrite
on va lui livrer les médicaments à
domicile évidemment avec l'adresse du
patient nous allons lui livrer son
médicament en dedans de quatre heures et
donc pourra commencer son mandat de
quatre heures
l'institut pense pouvoir dévoiler les
résultats d'études 10 600 jours un
exploit en termes de rapidité ici
vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal